so when it comes to artificial
intelligence it is fabulous science
fiction premise to create a machine that
will kill you and I very much enjoyed ex
machina where the guy builds these babe
robots and then there's trouble there's
trouble and I can't help but think about
Colossus the Forbin project where they
have these computers that control the
world's nuclear arsenals and then things
go wrong you know things just go wrong
in science fiction sense but I remind us
that if we can build a computer smart
enough to figure out that it needs to
kill us we could unplug it there are 2
billion people on earth who do not have
electricity they are not concerned about
the artificial intelligence computer
that decides to crash subway cars and
kill people there that's not their issue
they don't even have electricity or
clean running water so while we're
worried about artificial intelligence I
hope we also take the bigger picture
that none of this happens right now
without electricity and so we still
don't have anything but really primitive
means of generating electricity and I
look forward to the day when everybody
has clean water and quality electrical
over supply of quality electricity and
then we can take these meetings about
the problems of artificial intelligence
however are there any viewers listeners
here who have not been to an airport
where the train that takes you from
Terminal B to Terminal A is automated is
not automated everybody's been on an
automated train ok in the developed
world especially in the United States ok
those that's artificial intelligence
everybody has used a toilet that's
connected to a sewer system whose valves
are controlled by software that somebody
wrote that it's artificial intelligence
so keep in mind that if we unplug the
trains
or the sewer system valves the thing
will stop that we still control
electricity so this apocalyptic view of
computers that people write software for
to do tasks repetitive tasks or
complicated tasks that no one person can
sort out for him or herself that is not
new I do not see that it's artificial
I mean that it's inherently bad
artificial intelligence is not
inherently bad so just use your judgment
everybody let's we can do this I worked
on three channel auto pilots almost 40
years ago the plane lends itself and
humans designed the system it didn't
come from the sky it's artificially
intelligent it's good we can do this